♫♫
>> Tucker: BILL DeBLASIO ENJOYS
FLYING AROUND HIS CITY BY
HELICOPTER.
BUT HE’S A TRUE WARRIORS FOR THE
CLIMATE.
YOU CAN TELL BECAUSE HE’S USING
TAXPAYER MONEY TO SUE OIL
COMPANIES OVER CLIMATE CHANGE.
PUTTING OTHER PEOPLE’S MONEY
WHERE HIS MOUTH IS.
KEN SAYS IT’S OKAY TO BREAK THE
LAW FOR THE SAKE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THANKS FOR BEING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I HEARD YOU CALL SOMEBODY, WHAT
WAS IT, DEMAGOGUE, LITTLE --
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THEN, THIS
IS NOW, KEN.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT SEGMENT,
DIFFERENT GUEST, GLAD TO SEE
YOU.
>> WONDER WHAT I GOT MYSELF
INTO.
>> Tucker: NO, NO, NO.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, I WON’T
CALL THAT YOU OR HOPEFULLY
ANYONE ELSE THAT EVER AGAIN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WHY CAN THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CALL HIMSELF A WARRIOR
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE IF HE
USES A HELICOPTER TO GET AROUND
THE CITY?
WHEN HE COULD TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, KEY GET THOSE
QUESTIONS ALL THE TIME.
IT IS A VERY FAIR QUESTION.
I JUST THINK WE’RE TRYING TO
CHANGE AN ENTIRE SYSTEM HERE,
PARTLY CAN YOU DO THAT BY YOUR
OWN BEHAVIORS.
THAT’S EXEMPLARY.
I WOULD THINK ANYBODY WHO’S
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
THEIR OWN CARBON IMPACT.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE’RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE POLITICAL CHANGE IN
AMERICA AS IT IS.
AND IT’S HARD TO DO THAT WITHOUT
BURN SOMETHING FOSSIL FUELS.
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE ARE PRACTICAL LIMITS TO
PEOPLE’S ABILITY TO LIVE OUT
THEIR BELIEFS.
BUT DO I THINK IT CALLS INTO
QUESTION THE SINCERITY OF A
PERSON WHOO’S FRAME LITTLE
DEBATE IN MORAL TERMS IF HE
FALLS SO FAR SHORT F I’M A
SHOEXMAN FOR PETA BUT OPERATE A
SLAUGHTER HOUSE ON THE SIDE I’M
LESS BELIEVABLE.
>> THAT MAKES SENSE.
I DON’T THINK CLIMATE CHANGE IS
FRAMED IN MORAL TERMS.
IT’S PUT IN PRACTICAL, PRAGMATIC
TERMS.
WE’RE FACING THE CATACLYSMIC
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT HAS MORAL IMPLICATIONS BUT
PRACTICAL LIVING IMPLICATIONS.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO HOW IS IT THAT IN PURSUIT OF
LIVING OUT YOUR OPINIONS ON
CLIMATE CHANGE YOU BELIEVE YOU
OUGHT TO BE ALLOWED TO VIOLATE
THE LAW?
>> I’M NOT SURE I’D SAY I WANT
TO BE ALLOWED TO VIOLATE THE
LAW.
WHAT I BELIEVE, IS THAT IN
TAKING THE ACTIONS, SUCH AS WE
RECENTLY DID, WHEN WE FACE
CHARGES AND WHEN WE GO TO COURT,
IT IS APPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO SMAN TO THE JURY WHY WE
DID, WHAT WE DID.
AND TO BE ABLE TO CALL SOME
EXPERT WITH ITS THAT WOULD
TESTIFY TO THE FACTS AS WE
UNDERSTAND THEM.
>> Tucker: BUT THAT’S NOT, I
MEAN, THAT’S NOT REALLY AN ACT
OF CONSCIENCE.
TYPICALLY WHEN PEOPLE PROTEST
WHAT THEY THINK IS AN UNJUST
SYSTEM AND ARE PUNISHED FOR IT,
THEY SAY PART OF THE ACTION,
PART OF THE REASON IT’S A NOBLE
ACTION, IS BECAUSE THEY ACCEPT
THE CONSEQUENCES.
YES, I KNOW IT’S AGAINST THE
LAW, I DID IT ANYWAY.
WHY DON’T DO YOU THAT?
>> I’M NOT TRYING TO GET OFF
HERE, CERTAINLY ANYBODY ENGAGES
IN DIRECT ACTION, IF YOU’RE
GOING TO STAND THERE AND GET
ARRESTED, WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT YOU MAY WELL BE PUNISHED
FOR IT.
IN THE ACTION THAT I DID, AFTER
TWO TRIALS, I WAS CONVICTED OF
BURGLARY.
I’M NOT PROTESTING BURGLARY, I
HAVE HAD MY HOUSE BROKEN INTO,
BURGLARY LAWS ARE GOOD.
ALL I’M SAYING, I’D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN TO THE JURY WHY
I DID WHAT I DID AND CALL SOME
EXPERTS THEN IT’S UP TO THEM.
THE JURY CAN DECIDE.
I’VE NOW SAID --
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT DOES THIS, DO YOU THINK,
APPLY TO OTHERS, DO YOU THINK
THE GUY WHO SHOT GEORGE TILLER,
ABORTIONIST, ANYONE SHOT BY
ANTI-ABORTIONISTS, OUGHT TO
EXPLAIN THEIR POSITION TO THE
JURY AND THAT WOULD BE
EXCULPATORY?
>> I DO NOT THINK IT SHOULD BE
AN EASY PROCESS BY ANY MEANS.
IT IS A DIFFICULT ONE.
RARELY DO JUDGES ALLOW
PRESENTING A NECESSITY DEFENSE.
IF YOU DO PRESENT A NECESSITY
DEFENSE, THERE ARE REALLY HIGH
HURDLES THAT YOU HAVE TO -- I
THINK THAT IS APPROPRIATE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK
ANTI-ABORTION ACTIVISTS SHOULD
ABE LOUED TO DO THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU MENTION WAS
VIOLENT.
I’M COMMITTED TO NONVIOLENCE.
>> Tucker: HOW ABOUT BLOCKING A
CLINIC?
>> BLOCKING A CLINIC, I THINK IF
PEOPLE BELIEVE THIS IS WHAT --
ACTUALLY, I THINK THE PRO-LIFE
MOVEMENT IS PRETTY COMPARABLE IN
A LOT OF WAYS TO THE POLITICAL
SITUATION THAT CLIMATE ACTIVISTS
FACE, INSOLUBLE PROBLEM THAT
MAINSTREAM POLITICS, BOTH
PARTIES, AREN’T DEALING WITH.
THAT IS THE CLASSIC SITUATION.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEMS LIKE A
FAIR POSITION.